[Musique]
merci d'avoir été aussi libre à vous
mobiliser pour cette pétition vous êtes
déjà douze à avoir signé je suis très
très ému c'est vachement bien c'est
comme ça qu'on va pouvoir faire ployer
le lobby des minéraux et c'est ça qu'on
veut parce que ce moyen de les mots
techniques pour se souvenir de la dureté
c'est vraiment c'est révoltant donc
youpi et comme je ne suis pas nigel
farage je ne vais pas juste vous
abandonner après que vous ayez dit non
je vais vous proposer une solution
alternative
et pour ça j'ai été fouillé toute la
littérature scientifique de la science
de la mnémotechnique mais avant il faut
que je vous parle d'un homme
cet homme c'est georges française c'est
un américain qui a la plus grande
collection de coprolithe connu à se
mouiller et qu'il en a plus de 1200
cette pièce maîtresse s'appelle richesse
c'est un kaka fossiles qui remonte à
plus de 20 millions d'années mais
surtout georges fransen n'a rien à voir
avec notre histoire donc nous disions le
meilleur moyen de démo technique pour se
souvenir de la dureté des minéraux pour
ça je propose de passer en revue les
différents critères qui font un bon
moyen mnémotechnique c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est
plus
[Musique]
donc l'idée c'est de faire naître des
images en faisant appel à son
imagination puis de les lier entre elles
ces images donc ces informations par le
biais de l'histoire qu'on raconte est de
rendre ces histoires marquantes grâce
aux émotions et aux convoquant des cinq
sens donc le principe c'est en gros de
créer des faux souvenirs pour que les
vrais puisse s'implanter partant de cela
je vous propose ce moyen mnémotechnique
[Musique]
un bébé avec les faits ce talk et va
voir un gipsy qui est en calcif parce
qu'il fait chaud et lui dire regarde
regarde le regarde mon téléphone
regarde ce que j'ai trouvé c'est trop
bien et lui montre l'appli faith ap et
donc le gypsy lui dis ouah c'est trop
beau il vient et c'est avec une photo de
jean michel aphatie et donc qu'ils
prennent la photo de jean michel aphatie
il applique le filtre viau et là en fait
c'est juste le même jean michel aphatie
simplement il a une orthèse un bras et
il elle montre à quartz voilà donc il se
marre bien quand soudain arrive dans la
pièce adriana karembeu elle-même qui est
topless et qui dit oui bonjour je viens
faire la quête à une association
caritative
on est pauvre encore un don et tout le
gypsy qui tombe complètement fou
amoureux belle lui offre son plus beau
trésor il sort de sa poche un diamant
voilà donc ma petite histoire se
souvenir de la dureté des minéraux je
vous invite maintenant affaire pose sur
cette vidéo enfin après que j'ai fini ma
phrase et puis à essayer de répéter vous
même la petite histoire en essayant de
vous rappeler des minéraux qui vont à
chaque étape
j'attends
[Musique]
si vous avez fait poser vous avez réussi
à vous souvenir de l'histoire c'est bien
petit vous avez fait poser vous n'avez
pas réussi à vous souvenir de l'histoire
c'est mal je vous invite à revenir un
petit peu avant vers une minute 13 et a
essayé de vous repassez l'histoire et de
répéter si vous y arrivez
c'est bien si vous n'avez pas fait pas
du tout c'est très bien parce que ça
prouve que vous ne vous laissez pas
dicter votre vie par une vidéo youtube
et maintenant allez me donner des sous
sur youtube mais c'est pas tout se
souvenir de l'histoire maintenant ce qui
est bien c'est de se souvenir
durablement delà de l'échelle de dureté
des minéraux c'est un truc qui nous sert
tous les jours dans la vie quotidienne
ce que recommande la science c'est de
remobiliser ses connaissances donc de
répéter la petite histoire une heure
après le premier apprentissage puis un
jour après puis une semaine après puis
un mois après et enfin six mois après
donc revenez me voir dans six mois et
parlez-moi d'adriana karembeu topless
voilà donc tout ce système là il est
dégueulasse l'objectif ce système promu
mort isation système de mémorisation ça
fait appel à notre mémoire épisodique
notre mémoire épisodique c'est ce qui se
passe sur nos souvenirs intimes donc
c'est pour ça qu'on fait appel aux
émotions au sens machin tout ça le
principe donc c'est de transférer
progressivement ses souvenirs de la
mémoire épisodique à la mémoire
sémantique celles qu'on utilise le
résultant pour parler au quotidien par
exemple celle qui me permet de dire
aujourd'hui que paris est la capitale
des gros coup pourquoi commencer par la
mémoire épisodique c'est parce qu'elle
est le plus facile d'accès même si elle
est moins fiable donc c'est pour ça que
c'est une bonne porte d'entrée mais
c'est bien après de transférer sa vers
la mémoire sémantique et donc c'est pour
ça qu'il faut répéter et répéter et
répéter le moyen démo technique
[Musique]
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo et pour
finir une petite plage musicale pour se
détendre
[Musique]
beaucoup
c'est un
[Musique]
wall
ayew
[Musique]
à
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]